I'm Chelsea Miller I'm a knife maker and
today I've been challenged to make a
knife in six levels of increasing
complexity so obviously there are so
many subcategories of knives depending
on the knife makers bent towards
tradition versus ingenuity knives can
become so complex for example making
your own Damascus steel which is a
process of Forge welding hundreds of
pieces of Steel together before you even
begin to shape the blade what I love
about knives is it really the complexity
level is endless you could keep going
beyond just the basic steps needed so
we're gonna focus on really the number
of steps to get to a highly functioning
knife beyond any decoration you wanted
to add to that later on so just remember
this is my personal take my personal
unique style in the knives that I make
and all of the materials that I use are
repurposed level-one wood knife the wood
knife would be the most simple level
because we're only working with one
material which is the wood itself all
you need to do is source the wood we'll
trace out our desired shape in the piece
of wood cut it out sand it and oil it so
we're only using very few tools here
important things to remember when
cutting out the shape is to keep
yourself protected so protecting your
eyes protecting your ears and making
sure that your fingers are always
outside the reach of the blade leave
yourself a little room there's no adding
material once you've cut so it's
important to give yourself a little bit
of wiggle room and cut it a little
bigger than you've traced I mean really
the worst thing that could happen is
either you cut into the shape that
you've traced or maybe you go too deep
when you're sanding it in which case
it's not really a big deal to just start
over most important thing when sanding
is not to remove too much material
because again you can't go back start at
a coarse grit and increase the tightness
of the grits you end up with a very fine
sanding of the knife this will keep the
moisture out of your knife it'll keep a
really nice smooth finish on the blade
and that's very important if you don't
take the knife down to a really
fine smooth finish it will be really
uncomfortable in your hand it'll feel
sort of hairy and your fingers also food
will get stuck to it and the process of
it being wet and then drying will tend
to dry out the knife a lot also wood
loves oils so if you apply a mineral oil
maybe a little beeswax in there that'll
help keep the moisture out of the
material I like to just use my bare
hands
get that oil right in there into the
grain used to rub it between your
fingers afterwards for the next level
we're gonna stay with a wood blade and
we're gonna add a wood handle on top of
that level to wood knife with handle so
you'll start with a block of wood you'll
trace your desired shape in the block of
wood cut that out and then you're gonna
take another wood lay that over your cut
piece and trace a handle make sure you
leave a little extra space so that you
can cut it just a little bit bigger than
your original knife piece also it's a
good idea to examine the piece that
you'll be using for your handle and make
sure that it's got something going on
that it's got character then you'll go
through the process of sanding your
blade sanding the wood handle and then
you'll drill holes through the knife and
the handle pieces glue them together pin
them together let them set and then
you'll begin sanding both those
materials at the same time til it's all
smooth so when it comes to attaching the
handle to the wood blade you want to
really make sure that you've sanded each
piece to fit so you don't have a big gap
where you're gonna see epoxy you're
gonna see the glue you want to make sure
it's really snug keep applying that wood
handle until it's perfect if it's got a
little bump you sand a little more test
it sand a little more test it until you
line it up perfectly before you want to
glue it because again there's no going
back once you glue it so going into the
next level we're gonna introduce metal
into the equation level 3 metal butter
knife so as opposed to making a wooden
knife with a wooden handle now we've
brought in this other element which is
the metal and the difference in the
metal is different machinery you're
gonna want to protect yourself in a
different way you don't want to be
breathing in those metal fumes you're
bringing in a whole new skill set in
working with a brand-new material so to
make a metal butter knife you will
source them
and what I like to use are mechanic's
rasps so I'll find a rasp trace out the
shape and then I'm gonna use a grinding
stone to rough out that shape so much
about working at the grinding stone is
about posture if you're standing there
like I am four hours a day you want to
make sure that you're not overworking
your body because it'll really start to
take a toll you're using a lot of force
they have to be very aware of keeping my
elbows in keeping like in in a straight
line so that I've got a lot of movement
and I'm not too rigid and then letting
the material really guide me unlike
working with wood where it wants to take
your lead the metal really will control
you
once I've ground out that shape I'll use
a series of sanding belts to bring it
down to just the shape and thickness
that I like then I'll drill holes for a
handle pins would handle glue it
together clamp it let it sit overnight
and then starts the sanding process so
the difference in sanding now this metal
butter knife versus the wooden knife is
that you're going to use difference in
pressure the wood is very soft and the
metal obviously is very hard so you need
to use a lot more resistance in the
final sanding of your knife which will
be hand sanding you want to make sure
that you use separate pieces of
sandpaper because say you're sanding the
metal material and then you move to the
handle you then rubbed bits of metal
particles into your wood which if you
are using a very light-colored wood
it'll just get into the grain and look
dirty so you want to make sure that you
separate your sandpaper for the wood and
your sandpaper for the handle in the
hand sanding process for the next level
we're adding a lot of stages to this
next knife level for paring knife the
difference in making a paring knife as
opposed to a butter knife is that now
we're using this knife to cut different
materials we are thinking about how we
need to cut vegetables or or fruit so we
need to think about the length of the
blade how it fits in our hand
what kind of edge we want and also we
want to make sure that that blade is
structurally sound so making sure that
the molecular structure is going to last
a really long lifetime and hold an edge
forever
well maybe not forever but so as opposed
to using the grinding stone to create
our shape for the paring
like we did with the metal butter knife
we're gonna need to remove a lot more
material this time so the best process
that I like to use is to heat it in the
Forge forging is a process of heating
your material and then hammering it out
spreading the material forward an
important thing to remember when you're
hammering keep your movements really
close to the body so instead of having
your arm way out here and putting a lot
of stress on your back your shoulder
your elbow to keep it really tight it's
like trying to do anything without using
your core a lot of the techniques and
the steps it will be going through
requires a lot of really centered core
strength so things to be aware of when
you're forging are the fact that you're
working with a very hot piece of metal
and you're working with machinery that
gets also very hot and as you're
hammering bits of that material can fly
off in multiple directions so you want
to make sure that you are protected
against heat so I create a rough shape
there then I move to the grinding stone
to rough out a more specific shape then
move to the sanding belt bring it down
to mostly the shape that I want
we'll have to heat treat it heat
treating is a process of heating and
cooling your material to bring out the
optimal characteristics when we put our
paring knife into the Forge we're
heating it to a very extreme temperature
and then manipulating it as it cools
down so all the electrons in the
material all the carbon is scattering
about the material so I like to use a
heat treat oven it's a very controlled
preset temperature that way I can be
sure that I've got the optimal heat
treating going on so the temperature at
which you're going to heat treat depends
on the grade of Steel that you're using
the grade of steel that I use is
repurposed tool steel which is 1095 I
will heat treat between 14 75 and 1,500
degrees I put it a little high because
every time you open the door the
temperature will drop about a hundred
degrees so opening and closing will
change the temperature I want to let it
sit for at least five to ten minutes at
1500 degrees before I remove the
material and quench it into a warm oil
now one of the reasons I like to use my
heat treat oven is because it's very
consistent when you're heat treating
with a torch or in a forge oftentimes
the rate of temperature at different
areas on the knife can be can be
different and therefore
or certain places in your knife can be
weaker or more brittle it's very
important to avoid having a brittle edge
because you'll never be able to keep it
sharp and there's a possibility that you
could break it by bending it or applying
too much force then begin the process of
building a handle finding the wood
cutting the shape for the handle pinning
and gluing it and then again the process
of sanding the handle and sharpening and
sanding the blade there are obviously
many ways that you can go about
sharpening a knife I prefer to use a
series of wet stones of course there's a
big learning curve in wet stones it
takes a lot of practice to get your
angle right and the number one key is
your angle it's a great satisfactory
moment when you've been working on your
knife and you can really see the
progress you've made besides that I
would recommend something that sits on
your countertop and you slide it through
with a moving belt knife sharpeners I
don't really love or really the
on-the-go that you hold in one hand two
pieces of tungsten just vide together
that you slide your knife through
personally I prefer a whetstone when
you're using a whetstone really the most
important key is to maintain your angle
now I'm so familiar with sharpening my
own knives that I can essentially
freehand on the belt sander and then
clean any of it up on the wet stones to
create the edge so if you're just
starting out the best way is to set up a
jig on your sanding belt to the exact
angle you place your knife in the jig
it's the same every time and then you
get that muscle memory of where that
exact angle is some people prefer to
always use a jig then you just know it's
preset you know your angle I like to be
a little more loose in form makes me
feel good when I when I'm free handing
it and I can see that I've done a good
job so it's really a personal preference
now going into the next level we're
adding on a little more complexity here
because we're gonna be using this knife
for another range of tasks so we need to
be more mindful of how this knife is
gonna be balanced the shape in which
you're gonna be using it for whatever
things are gonna be cutting and also for
the user themselves level 5 kitchen
knife made from a pre-made blank so this
knife really would be between a paring
knife and a chef's knife something that
you would grab in your kitchen for all
those in-between kind of tasks at this
level we're going to be using pre-cut
materials so we're gonna order a
pre-made blank
and then also a pre-made handle so
oftentimes you'll see these in starter
kits you can order the pre-made blank it
arrives already cut to the shape and
with a preformed beveled edge so really
we're cutting out our blank handle piece
attaching it and then just putting an
edge on that pre beveled edge it's very
important to know what kind of bevel
you're working with what kind of bevel
your knife has so a single bevel knife
is a knife that is completely straight
all the way to the edge on one side and
has a slight bevel and an end the edge
on the other side these are generally
used in Korean and Japanese cooking
where you're cutting raw fish or you're
creating really long slices and
vegetables and a double bevel knife is
pretty much for everything else in your
kitchen far more common where you have a
bevel and an angle on both sides of the
knife that's much more useful when
you're cutting meat or you're cutting
large vegetables it's a little more
versatile and also easier to sharpen and
maintain in your kitchen on my knives I
use a double bevel and the angle is
about 17 to 20 degrees the main
difference between this pre-made blank
and the paring knife that we just made
is that it's arriving many steps to your
door that we've already put in the work
for so instead of sourcing your material
you'll buy that material instead of
shaping it on the grinding stone or
forging it in the Forge it'll already
arrive in the shape that you want
instead of applying that beveled edge
it'll appear with a beveled edge on it
instead of heat treating it will arrive
heat treated so the process that you'll
begin at will be fitting it to the
handle so we'll cut out those wood
handles attached it to the knife as we
like and then glue pin sand and sharpen
that blade so the steps are reduced in
making it but it's far more complex in
your kitchen because you'll use it for
many more tasks than you would the
paring knife it also has a much more
substantial blade and a longer blade so
the next and final level that we're
going to cover today will be the most
complex level six chef's knife from raw
materials so in terms of sourcing raw
materials for this chef's knife there
are a lot of options to choose from you
can choose types of Steel depending on
the kind of things that you want to be
cooking in your kitchen you could choose
stainless steel for your blade it's a
little bit different in the way that you
work with it but generally the process
is the same
I prefer to use high carbon steel as
it's got a lot more characteristics
takes on a patina over time the
relationship you have with your knife is
much more involved in oiling and drying
the knife you might find that stainless
steel is a little harder to manipulate
than high carbon steel really is just
about personal choice so in terms of
cutting your raw material there are
several ways you can go about it you
could use an oxy acetylene torch you
could use a water jet my personal
preference is to use a plasma cutter
because it's a very thick piece of
material so the plasma cutter is the
most efficient way I have found to cut
through a material that thick in a
matter of seconds there aren't so many
things that can go wrong in this stage
in terms of cutting out the shape
because you can always fix those up
later this is really the most rough part
of the process you just want to be
obviously really aware of safety you're
working with plasma so obviously you
want to make sure that you steer clear
that your body is free of any falling
debris so I use a piece of metal
guarding the lower half of my body and
also making sure that you have a
respirator because the fumes released
are not so good for your health a key
piece of safety gear are welding goggles
because the flame of the plasma cutter
is bright enough to burn your retina you
want to make sure that you have mobility
and you maintain an equal distance
between the material and the flame I
have found that the best thing that
works for me is straddling a chair and
resting one arm over the other that way
I have one arm to stabilize the other as
I cut if you were to veer away from that
direct angle you may come off to one
side creating a lot of slag which means
a lot of the material is sort of folding
back up on itself and becoming very hard
and crisp along the edge it also makes
our next stage a lot longer where we're
cleaning all of that up on the grinding
stone now the reason we don't use the
Forge for this particular knife is
because my particular chef's knife also
incorporates a grater on the side which
is left over from the original purpose
of the tool so we're going to use the
grinding stone as opposed to the Forge
so that we keep that intact we keep that
zester grater intact
if we were to heat it in the Forge and
Hammer it we would lose that texture
altogether so second stage at the
grinding stone removing excess material
third step will be at
sanding belt sanding bringing that knife
down to a finer shape and then heat
treating finding a handle from raw
materials attaching the handle gluing
pinning letting that cure and then a
process of sanding sharpening and
finishing so I think we've covered a lot
today obviously we could continue on
with other levels of complexity but
we're gonna stop at this level today
we've outlined the fundamental steps of
creating a functional characteristic
knife thanks wired